it once seemed like a far-off future a
world where robots and computers take
away our jobs but from automated
concussed immerse service reps to
self-driving cars that future appears to
be gaining on us and American workers
are growing increasingly concerned that
is the finding of some recent polls
according to an article in Wired
magazine and we are joined by Wired's
site director Jason tans Jason good
morning morning okay so the future is
now
it seems isn't it always where are we
collectively in terms of our acceptance
or apprehension about automation we have
a lot of mixed feelings about us so I
think if you look at these polls there
was a poll out by Ipsos and one by Pew
generally speaking in the general sense
people are anxious when it gets to
specifically how it works in their lives
people feel okay it's kind of like how
people hate Congress but what their
congressmen you know that's right
exactly they they are they feel pretty
good about things like e-retail and
banking and things like that they are
more anxious about stuff that isn't here
yet right so generally people feel more
favorably about stuff they're more
familiar with yeah which kind of makes
sense with the exception of automated
phone trees which they hate one of the
most looming changes occurring here is
self-driving cars they're gonna be
tested in New York very soon even are we
ready for that well judging by the polls
we have a lot of anxiety about it which
kind of makes sense it was a little bit
surprising to me because we write about
self-driving cars all the time and
people within that community make a very
convincing case that sure they're going
to be much safer than humans yeah but
just as you know flying in planes are a
lot there's a lot it's a lot safer than
driving people still get anxious about
getting in planes in a way they don't
with cars because it's out of their
control
my concern actually is is that people
we've defined freedom in America for so
long by your ability to get in a car and
go ever you want and drive yourself and
I'm not sure we're ready for the
psychological change that that's not
gonna happen anymore well I think we're
actually starting to see a lot of
autonomous features rolling out in cars
they just don't call them that so you
know adaptive cruise control if I lock
braking systems things like that so it
you know I think if technologists and
car companies are looking at
I'm sure they are they may be tempted to
sort of make some big grand statement
about welcome to the age of autonomous
driving that's probably not the right
way to do it probably the way to do it
is more of a frog in the in the you know
water getting slowly heated up kind of
thing I mean in terms of the economic
impact I mean I mission is going to have
an effect on the American job market it
sounds like the sectors of
transportation manufacturing those are
gonna be very affected
is there any sector that is impervious
to automation well that is a really good
question and I think nobody really knows
the answer to that there are kind of two
different strains of thought in Silicon
Valley around the world that automate
automation might play one is look the
when we went to the Industrial
Revolution it's not like people stopped
working we found other jobs out now
obviously it takes a while and how do
you take care of people in the mean time
but the other school of thought is no
you know what AI is actually a
completely different kind of thing yeah
and it's you know like the singularity
or something like that and we have to
think about how society is going to
rearrange itself when we don't even need
something like employment and then you
get into ideas like universal basic
income right and things like that so I
there is a big conversation happening
within Silicon Valley there's on that's
a that's a that's a very prevalent
concern among a lot of people I've
talked to that the jobs aren't gonna be
there well yeah I mean you're looking
right now at when machines can do things
so much more efficiently than humans
yeah well or even when you look at the
the economics of the digital industry
where you can do so much more you know
if you look at the wealthiest companies
right now they employ somebody so many
fewer people sure but what about those
industries that need the human touch
doctors caregivers I mean that does not
those seem like places where you want an
actual Homo Sapien and not a robot I
tend to agree and I think there is an
there's an alternate way of thinking
about the role that AI might play in our
jobs which is that perhaps it actually
makes us better at our jobs and and you
know allows us to do things we weren't
able to do before so for instance you
know a doctor who doesn't have to read
every single medical journal but you
know I want a doctor to read everything
but in AI could probably do it better
and could maybe diagnose things better
than a doctor could because they have
access to all the information but then
the doctor does do the human patient you
know interface stuff Jason thank you
very much for being with us this morning
it's all gonna be different
just don't know how